you have to be willing to outwork
everybody in the world until you callus
over the victims mentality that the
world is out to get you because of you
are the only you got a change - man we
live in the world now that's so kind we
we find the kind way around everything
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe nation
he's David Goggins and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success volume 9
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have a brutal work ethic you don't
need to have this humongous GPA and all
astir [ __ ] what you need is the one
thing I talked on my book which is
straight up brutal work ethic you have
to be willing to outwork everybody in
the world and that that that's the hard
part
that's the hard part this isn't like
some five-step process where you can do
these five steps you're gonna end up
with this magical world now I'm
basically teaching you how to callus
over your victims mentality I'm teaching
you how to like I did 67,000 pull-ups
and training for the pull-up record I
was seriously calloused in my hands to
protect them what I'm trying to do with
people's teach them how to find more
themselves to where they empower
themselves I'm all about the underdog
rule number two change your internal
dialogue the most important conversation
is the one you have with yourself you
wake up with it you walk around with it
you go to bed with it eventually you act
on it sometimes you act on it good
sometimes bad you got to change the
internal dialogue that person in your
head that's talking that to you until
you change the internal dialogue in your
head until you callus over the victims
mentality that the world is out to get
you because of you are the only you got
change - man yeah but you don't
understand my life David yeah I do
that's the thing about it and that's why
I can talk about but yeah I get your
saying a lot of folks don't honor I kept
many I once had that mentality that no
one understands what the going through
and if you keep that mentality you're
gonna stay in the same exact spot that
you're in that no one understands me
there's a whole there's millions of
people why do you think a book that I
self-published you know is doing so well
with your story that's so [ __ ] up you
like I'll never give up I went to a
publishing house like who's gonna
resonate with
story no one's gonna buy this book I'm
like are you not in the world are you
not in society you're never alone
everybody's going through so when people
get this mentality of like you
understand me
you can throw a lock to someone that can
understand you if they're willing to
break themselves down and stop hiding a
lot of people understand you mmm but you
got to stop hiding and that's why I tell
people a lot of people are going through
they just hide better than you did
that's all they did
it was hiding better rule number three
be brutally honest we live in the world
now that's so kind we we find the kind
way around everything like if you don't
look good
I have to find a kind way of saying I
don't like your shirt
right that's not the approach if that's
the approach you're looking for that
book is not for you you can't hurt me is
not for you the approach you have to
take at least I took you take whatever
point you want the conversation had to
be a real honest conversation in the
accountability mirror guess what I was
fat don't find a kind word to say that
you know what I've gained some weight no
you're fat when I couldn't read not like
hey you know even learn disability no I
cannot read of a fourth grade reading
level I'm struggling and sometimes I
call myself stupid not in a way to put
myself down so don't take it like my god
those are so hurtful
yeah the hurtful this honest the
conversation has to become an honest
conversation of where you're at mentally
where am I at mentally I look like I
feel like I'm not this I'm I'm falling
behind in school I'm lazy my house is a
mess you have to look at what it is and
call it what it is don't find words to
make yourself feel better because that's
what so we hang around people that make
us feel better that tell us what we want
to hear not what we need to hear and so
we stay away from those people and we
stay away from those people like our
internal dialogue becomes that kind it's
okay it's not okay
so that's where it starts it starts with
that accountability of it's not okay
anymore this can no longer be okay and
calling yourself out for exactly what
you are in exactly how you need to fix
it rule number four believe as you know
I'm a serious introvert and very afraid
of people I got just so much growing up
that this is uncomfortable for me all
these podcast me that's why I post once
a week yeah I don't you know people are
ugly people are nasty they make me want
to choke the [ __ ] out of them and
they're just nasty people so I stay away
from them but the one thing I realized
why I wrote the book is honestly I have
a story to tell as we all have a story
to tell and what I realized on my
journey was a lot of us don't believe
that we can achieve the impossible and
along my journey I started realizing man
I got tell some people about this man
like I discover something that some
people have but don't even know all of
us have it but along this way I wasn't
like I said I wasn't a theorist I became
a practitioner and I was like my god I'm
busting down so many barriers of like
I've learned disability okay but I'm
catching up with everybody I I figured
that out I figured out all these
negative things in my life that were
keeping me in this hole like I gotta
tell people man that hang on a second
man you can achieve the absolute
impossible if you want to build more
confidence check of my 250 for
confidence series it's free the link to
join is in the description below you
will never learn from people if we
always tap-dance around the truth
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today rule number
five celebrate your victories you are
pretty good about celebrating the
victories along the way and celebrating
yourself I talk about with my fiance
every single day I talked about with her
two hours today I said we are grinding
so hard that we are losing the vantage
point of what we
accomplished today we got podcast
podcast interview flying do this do that
like stop stop it's just me and you and
this mom-and-pop thing that we that that
we're doing look at what if this book is
that right now it's crazy look how many
people were touching shut shut up and
just think for a second that's the stop
because all we did was talk about this
and this react you know enjoy this for a
sec that's we have to take time it rule
out with the we've accomplished that's
an evolution for you man huge huge but
it's a very different David Goggins and
even from a couple of years ago huge
because you have to what is all about
I'm gonna keep on grinding that's not
what I'm saying what I'm saying though
is you have to respect what you've done
take a second not live in it not sit
around and say I'm good sit back and say
let me look at the vantage point now
that I'm at we went there that's why you
reset the vantage point get the tactical
advantage if you get the tactical
advantage too quick and start fighting
you gotta take a second to take
observations at where I'm at what have I
done I'm on the right spot
I'm obviously in the right spot right
now now we can go back to fighting rule
number six don't overthink things I get
a lot of questions about how I lost so
much weight
people want to know how they can get
started so basically you're thinking too
much off the back run lost my weight I
look for a trainer I ain't do all that
thinking I didn't go on Jenny Craig I
didn't do all that what I do is I
basically stop eating so much food I cut
my calories down so as far as the
workout goes we overthink that also
until you find a trainer go out there
and start walking put some shoes on
start running go to the gym do the
elliptical trainer it's not rocket
science
a lot of folks talk about overtraining
you got trained first before you can
over trained sometimes you wake up in
the morning time in you're sore and you
like you're over trying no you got sore
legs get out your old head they stop
overthinking it
rule number seven don't forget your
roots the world is so fast-paced the
water is so noisy
so my conversation now a lot of times is
my god slow down the world can take you
here here be here be there be everywhere
and I lose myself sometimes
so I catch myself in the airport I catch
myself in the playing around writing
stuff down okay remember this humor that
look oh hey hang on a second God what
got you here this isn't what got you
here slow down
go back to the quiet place of that dirty
mirror in that seven dollar month place
used to live in that's where you grew
you so I so that's what I'm constantly
reminding myself we'll go back to your
roots now I'm not saying go back to hell
I'm saying don't forget where you come
from as you start to explode out of the
gate when you become someone my
conversation is do not forget your roots
do not forget your roots
don't let this become so big that you
lose yourself amongst the noise go back
to the quietness of what made you
successful rule number eight don't lose
your real self I used to hate people not
liking me well the hardest thing in the
world for me at a young age was my guys
want to fit in I want to fit in I want
you to like me so that's a horrible
place to be in life because you lose
yourself when you want to fit in with
people so badly
normal people know better than you you
do whatever you can to fit in that's a
bad place to be
you lose yourself and trying to create a
character that other people will accept
and the that's what I found a lot of joy
man this is guy this is me not speaking
the third personal stuff I got some
going on still working on myself take
your leave you don't like me take a
number and get in line man rule number
nine be relatable the motivation where
people are losing all these people who
come out here and talk about how great
they are and I see it all
it makes me sick man get real with
yourself people can not relate to you
man you are unrelatable when you come
out here and say hey man
I'm the baddest never live ok great well
I what am I gonna learn from you you
learn from people who are willing to
tell you this is where I started from
this is how much I fell on my ass this
is how bad I used to really be I still
have those moments coz why you're human
we're all jacked up man we're all jacked
up and that's what makes my story
relatable I'm willing to let you in to
see I'm decently successful now but I
didn't come out like this man I didn't
come out that's the story is you have to
give people just a little bit of hope
there's no hope when they see greatness
in you everywhere you have to be able to
get yourself down to a level of check it
out man there's hope for you that's what
I'm trying to give you just a little bit
and rule number 10 the last hungry for a
very special bonus clip is stop making
excuses so which of its juice is it to
Cole where you live is it too hot where
you live is it ready too much nah Cyrus
a roof talk
maybe you're the only black person
applying for a job maybe the only female
maybe the only gay person job whatever
the [ __ ] it may be maybe that's in your
head
maybe that's your excuse for not being
better life's a real big picture when I
was young all those things got my head
black not smart enough single mom all
their books oh space in my head if
you're allowing people and things the
situation's choice patient then you're
losing last thing last one big head game
you play with yourself if you lose it's
because you allow life to get in your
head stay hard now I've got a special
bonus clip from David on how to add
value that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that is some of the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what's the excuse you're making that you
need to stop right now number two what's
the victory of yours and you can
celebrate this week on number three what
are you overthinking that you just need
to take action on I deployed I fought in
combat stuff like that first of all it's
hard to relate to that second of all I
to get all kind of approvals from people
to get that in the book and talk about
it and I want to go through that process
of hey can I put you know what I did in
Iraq in the book and stuff like that in
the book and I want my book to relate to
people you know there's enough Navy SEAL
books out there talking about you know
running gun and shooting them up stuff
like that that's never been I don't want
to be known as a Navy SEAL even though I
talk a lot like you know people want to
ask me about it you know Navy said that
was a snippet of my life you know I was
a snippet of my life and I want to be
known as somebody much more than that
who did a lot more than that so my book
is about helping people and I can't help
people through what I did in combat
mm-hmm I can help people by what I went
through in life life itself and I went
out too I mean it was it was intentional
to make this book about how can these
stories resonate and help people and you
know it wasn't my can't let me kiss my
own ass
if you want more David Goggins check out
the top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there because everybody
else's most people are weak the whole
thing about comfort zones is if you live
in one for too long that becomes your
norm